[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
YouTube has demonetized almost all of my
recent videos so if you're able please
consider supporting this channel by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought the world is now in its
fourth month of dealing with its most
recent pandemic since coronavirus was
declared a pandemic on March 11th 2020
we've seen the virus ravaged countries
around the world and in typical American
fashion we just had to be the best at
mishandling the crisis over the last few
months I and many other concerned
Americans begged people to listen to the
experts stay inside
wear their masks in the hopes that maybe
we could avoid a second wave to the
bafflement of the rest of the world
safety precautions that are empirically
proven to help prevent the spread of
disease are considered a political
opinion in the u.s. thanks to a
combination of our cult of capitalism
and weaponized idiocy of a certain type
of person the United States has
officially made the situation far worse
than it ever needed to be the president
business people and state level
officials begging for people to be
sacrificed on the altar of the market
rabid conservative decrying masks as a
plot to steal their freedom just look at
this chart consecutive days of record
numbers of new cases see the other
developed nations at the bottom of the
chart remember how news pundits were
saying that the high number of cases in
Europe was because of socialized
medicine they're pretty quiet now aren't
they it's almost as if the existence of
a profit motive in healthcare
discourages proper handling of a
pandemic but this video isn't about the
efficacy of different types of health
care in this episode we're going to talk
about the drug rum disappear the
pharmaceutical company Gilead and the
absolute depravity of how they've chosen
to price one of the only kovat
treatments in existence once upon a time
the US had a rule that required
pharmaceutical companies to charge
reasonable prices for the drugs they
developed with the help of government
funding that was 25 years ago and the
rule was rescinded by President Bill
Clinton despite the best efforts of more
progressive lawmakers Democrats and
Republicans came together to crush any
opposition and thus paved the way for
the last two and a half decades of
skyrocketing drug prices in America in
more recent years President Obama
refused to force drug companies to lower
their prices and the GOP blocked
legislation that would have let Medicare
negotiate for lower prescription drug
prices yet
picture this isn't a one party or the
other thing the neoliberal consensus as
it exists in America demands the
absolute freedom of corporations to seek
ever higher profits free from the
shackles of government regulation this
is great news for pharma executives and
shareholders who stand to make millions
of dollars off runaway drug prices and
the politicians who enable this racket
accept generous donations to their
re-election campaigns from these same
people I'm sure that's just a
coincidence the United States has the
highest drug prices in the world often
by a very wide margin in Canada a vial
of insulin cost 21 dollars the same
product produced in the same factory
cost 450 dollars in the u.s. if you have
type 1 diabetes and no insurance you're
looking at $3,000 a month just to stay
alive there's a reason we see so many
GoFundMe campaigns for medical issues in
the United States the vast majority of
people simply can't afford the
life-saving drugs they need but surely
some concessions would be made during a
pandemic right if people aren't able to
work or have been laid off and lost
their insurance there must be some way
for those affected by the virus to get
by if you haven't been completely
hoodwinked by the propaganda of
patriotism you probably won't be
surprised to learn that no there have
been no considerations made for the 40
plus million Americans out of work in
the middle of a plague can't afford your
medication you can either a dye or B go
into such tremendous debt that you'll
lose your life savings your home and all
your possessions and that brings us to
the drug Ram des aveer developed by the
american company Gilead REM des Vere has
proven to be an effective way to treat
coronavirus and hospitalized patients it
has no effect on mortality rates but for
those who do recover the drug tends to
shorten the recovery time by about four
days in the hospital or 31% the
treatment consists of a five-day series
of IV drips utilizing six vials of REM
de severe the cost of those vials 520
dollars each for a total cost of three
thousand one hundred and twenty dollars
there's also a reduced government price
which applies to a very limited number
of people and does not include those on
Medicare or Medicaid those most
vulnerable to getting seriously ill from
the disease the price for those lucky
few three hundred and ninety dollars per
vial for a total cost of two thousand
three hundred and forty dollars so in
the middle of a pandemic with tens of
millions of people without insurance or
a paycheck the ole
the available treatment costs two to
three thousand dollars that is absurd
but bear with me it gets much worse
Gilead CEO Daniel O'Day who was paid a
cool twenty nine point 1 million dollars
last year and whose company raked in 5.4
billion dollars in profits has been
trying to spin his pricing plan as a
selfless act for the good of the people
well I want to assure you Meg is that
both of those prices we focused on
making sure that that all patients would
have access and based upon you know this
price level whether you're covered by a
private insurer whether you're covered
by a government and sure whether you're
uninsured with koban 19 there will not
be an issue with access for REM to
severe here's the thing oday seems to
have a very different definition of
affordable than most average Americans
for perspective 40% of Americans
couldn't afford a surprise $400 expense
before the pandemic remember that price
per vial 40% of Americans couldn't pay
for one single day's worth of REM
disappear how are they supposed to
afford five days of that on top of the
incredibly expensive hospital stay for
most people it's just not possible you
may be thinking yeah it's expensive but
this isn't a charity the company has to
recoup their R&D costs first of all
that's a sickening mindset when so many
are suffering but to play your game
let's look at a couple of facts first
the cost of developing REM de severe was
offset considerably by tens of millions
of taxpayer dollars through the
government second a group of experts
crunched the numbers and found that
Gilead could turn a profit by charging
just ten dollars for the treatment 10
dollars three hundred times less than
what they're charging if you think that
sounds completely evil yeah I'd say so
too but if you're expecting a
pharmaceutical company to act with the
barest shred of compassion or basic
human decency you'll be sorely
disappointed okay but what about a
generic version of the drug it's not
uncommon to see cheaper copycat drugs
hit the market as an alternative to
pricey brand names you're right that
would make the situation much less grim
Gilead thought of that they decided
they'd rather not allow people the
option of buying a cheaper version so
they signed a deal preventing the
distribution of any generic form of REM
disappear in dozens of countries around
the globe including the world's poorest
nations they also attempted to mengapa
the production of the drug in order to
maximize their already massive profits
these goals would literally rather let
millions of people suffer and die than
lose out on a single dollar of profit
this behavior is sickening and the
people are right to be outraged after
all the development of the treatment was
funded by tens of millions of taxpayer
dollars we've already paid for the drug
at the very least it should be
affordable and really it should be
completely free given the circumstances
are you angry yet I can keep going while
other countries around the world have
worked hard to flatten the curve and get
their cases under control
the US has acted like the spoiled child
it is and completely mishandled the
situation as global cases decline in
most developed countries thanks to
effective planning testing and
prevention measures the US said screw it
this is too hard
everybody ignore the problem and go back
to work states reopened ignorant
Americans flocked to bars and
restaurants entitled people threw fits
at the suggestion that they should wear
a mask and guess what happened cases
exploded we're worse off now than ever
instead of doing the responsible thing
and enacting a true lockdown
the federal government has dragged its
feet conservative talk show hosts have
continued to peddle conspiracy theories
about the virus and state officials have
refused to slow reopening measures the
nation seems to have accepted its fate
hundreds of thousands will die but who
gives a [ __ ]
taking decisive action is too hard the
only thing the US has done in response
to the explosion of cases is to buy up
almost every single dose of remedy
severe for the next three months the
United States now owns the world's
entire supply of REM disappear for at
least a period of three months so what
this means effectively is that the
United States has swept up all of the
doses for three months meaning other
countries will not be able to to get
this drug but still the move really
harkens back to some of the tactics
ruthless tactics some have said we've
already seen from the United States and
snapping up personal protective
equipment back in the early days of the
pandemic we've had the worst response to
the virus by far but since we're a rich
country we can just shove aside the more
responsible nations and hoard the only
available treatment forget the at-risk
people in other countries who caught the
disease despite their best efforts let's
waste these treatments on the idiots who
think the virus is a Chinese Communist
Democrat hoax and who will go right back
out without a mask as soon
they leave the hospital this country's
behavior over the last six months has
been appalling and people around the
world have taken notice
we bully other nations we're fiercely
proud of our ignorance and we bankrupt
our own citizens when the only available
drug could be sold at a price that
everyone could afford the government
doesn't need to stand by and let Gilead
get away with their profiteering they
could enforce legislation that would
drastically reduce the price of
treatment but they won't the line
between corporations and the state has
become so blurred in the past few
decades that the distinction is no
longer discernible we are living under a
regime dominated by corporations and the
ultra wealthy and citizens of the United
States are not the only one suffering
how long will the rest of the world
allow this writhing hyper capitalist
death cult to rule international affairs
the pandemic has made a great many
things clear and the pricing of this new
treatment is just one more example of
the moral failure of the richest nation
on earth I mentioned at the beginning of
this video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon this
type of video while very important is
something that sponsors won't touch in
order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running I rely on Adsense
revenue sponsors and donations from
generous viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content I lose out on
both sponsors and Adsense if you enjoy
the kind of videos I'm producing and
you're able to chip in even a dollar a
month I would greatly appreciate the
support you can find my patreon page at
patreon.com slash second thought I've
also gotten a few requests to start a
discord so if that's something you would
enjoy as a patreon reward let me know in
the comments below you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week